[Music]
I'm joining the faculty if you hu got
friends you don't know I sold first
cheese of perfectionist explain what's
going on in there as much as you can for
me I'm actually really happy with the
preview because it's it it shows a lot
of fun that looks just a lot of the fun
that we had um our pilot is actually
really awesome when I read it I was so
happy because it has that familiarity of
PLL has that spark it has that danger
but it's new and it's fresh allison goes
into a whole new world and obviously I
love that they showed Mona with a knife
because who knows what Mona is up to
Mona I brought pie it's gonna be a
really big challenge for Alison to kind
of figure this new world out and it's
not gonna be easy but it's gonna be a
fun ride don't worry there's hope for
the innocent fans I know a lot of you
guys are wondering about know where I
was going I know I know she little for
sake it's just so funny because Mona and
Alison have had such a tumultuous
relationship where are they now the
perfectionist are they friends you know
what Alison is not sure what to make of
Mona there's some help along the way but
there's also some confusion Mona is a
tricky person to read and I'm actually
really excited to figure out why she's
here I'm trying to beg Marlena tell me
so we'll see she's got some tricks up
her sleeve
you